CHRIS PALMER: Hi, everybody.
Thanks for coming out.
Hopefully, you're having fun.
And hopefully, you
won't scream and cry.
I noticed that
when Alex said you
have to have HTTPS
for service workers,
and when Adrian said all the
cool new APIs need HTTPS too,
I'd like to thank you
all for not screaming.
Maybe you screamed inwardly.
But I really appreciate
it, because a lot
of times there's screaming.
So I want to help you find out
how to reduce the screaming.
And the good news is we can.
So first, I'd like to
pitch why you need TLS.
So I'm going to
be focusing mostly
on the performance aspects.
But first, I should motivate it.
So as you may know,
Chrome has the three goals
of speed, simplicity,
and security.
And I'm on the Chrome
security team, specifically
the secure usability team.
But all those things
have to go together.
We can't have an easy, fast
path to crash into the wall.
We can't have
terribly slow safety.
The safety can't
be too complicated.
So unless all those three
things are working in harmony,
we and our users are
going to be really sad.
So I'm going to
try to combine them
in a way that works
well for everyone.
So why do you need TLS?
I'm speaking today to you
as website developers.
And I want you to think
about the needs of your users
as well.
So your users care
about the data
that they're storing
in your application.
If your application
matters at all,
then it matters
to people who care
about the privacy,
the correctness,
whether or not it's
been mangled in transit.
Even if it's just
a news site, it
matters that they're
seeing the true news.
And sometimes the
news gets falsified.
And it really does happen.
For example, the
AP's Twitter account
was hijacked a while
back and caused
a two-seconds long
huge dip in the value
of some stocks because of a
false tweet that was sent out.
And someone made a lot of
money in those two seconds.
And so we want the news to be
true so that that kind of thing
has less chance of happening.
So any app, even the simplest
just publishing facts app,
should be safe.
And if you went to
all this trouble
to animate your UI nicely,
and to have cool graphics that
fit a material
design specification,
or whatever it might be,
you went to a lot of work.
And you want your users to see
the true work that you've done.
Unfortunately, when we don't
use a data channel that
provides authentication
and data integrity,
people between
you and your users
can mangle that experience.
And in fact, mangling
the user experience
is other people's
business model.
Messing with your business
model is someone else's business
model.
Here's an Ars Technica
story about how Comcast
is doing that for
their own gain.
So if that little thing appears
over your nice animations,
your users aren't going
to have a good experience.
So you want what you
built to get to people.
You also want your
privacy policy
to have any meaning
at all, which
requires the basic bare minimum
of security that TLS provides.
If you're monetizing
your site-- and I hope
you are, so that you can all
continue to have food and rent.
Either people are
paying for it directly--
and obviously you need to secure
people's payment instruments,
whether it's credit cards,
or Paypal, or whatever--
or, if you're
monetizing by ads, you
want to monetize your ads, and
not the ads that random people
are inserting, which,
incidentally, is a business
model.
So here is a person on
Stack Overflow asking,
I'd like to monetize--
I'm giving away Wi-Fi,
and I want to make
some money on it.
How bad would it be if I
took people's AdSense IDs,
and put in my own?
Would I get in a lot
of trouble for that?
And obviously the answer
is, what the hell, man?
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
CHRIS PALMER: But
people are doing that.
People want to do that.
When I've given forms
of this talk before,
I used to show-- I was at a
free Wi-Fi cafe in Austin.
And they were inserting
all sorts of goodness
on the front page
on Google, including
enticing me to download
software, which was possible
back then.
This is many years ago, when
Google Search wasn't on HTTPS.
And so people have been
doing this for a long time.
It's a stable strategy,
so we should all
get together and make it
not a stable strategy.
So TLS is good.
It's good for you.
It's good for users.
It's good for your business.
But let's get to the
performance part,
because it's a big
concern that people have.
Is this going to kill my speed?
We've talked about, we
want rendering to be fast.
It's got to be paper smooth.
And if TLS messes it
up, then I'm in trouble.
So let's figure out why not.
So HTTP/2 is the new
fancy HTTP version.
It's coming up.
We've built previous demo
versions of it before.
You may have heard of SPDY.
Google is using it
for lots of its sites.
Chrome supports it.
I think at least one
other browser does.
And HTTP/2 is
being standardized.
And we've experienced great
results-- speed improvements
when we turned on TLS.
And there's important
reasons for that.
So the first web was
for documents, HTTP/1.
HTTP/2 is about applications.
And it's tailored to the
needs of dynamic applications,
like real appy apps on the web.
So that requires that it
perform very differently
on the network than old-timey,
document-based HTTP.
So HTTP/2 brings a couple
super important features
to make apps responsive
on the internet.
One is multiplexing.
So if you think about HTTP/1,
you have this nice feature
where you can establish a TCP
connection, and then you say,
get/, and then they
give you the answer.
And if you want to save the
cost of having set up that TCP
connection, you can send
another get, or another post,
or whatever.
And that's very cool.
And it helps.
But we need more than that
for these super responsive
modern 2014 apps.
So for that, we have
multiplexing in HTTP/2.
In a sense, it's kind of
like streams within a stream.
If you've ever heard of
SCTP, it had a similar idea.
So once you set up
your HTTP connection
to a server, your
HTTP/2 connection,
you can interleave
requests and responses
at all different times
over the same connection.
And it can live
really long, and it
can be sending tons of stuff--
not even simple documents,
but constant streams,
video streaming,
interleaved with your get
the icon, get the avatar,
post a comment, all happening
on the same HTTP connection.
So that's a huge improvement
over mere pipelining
and mere persistence.
It also solved this problem
where, over one connection,
you really need to get that
CSS file to style the page.
But you're waiting
for the JPEG to come,
which you asked for first.
And so until that
JPEG comes, you're
not going to get any CSS.
And there's going to be that
style jank, where suddenly
the style appears too late.
So the head-of-line
blocking problem
is a big problem on networks.
And HTTP/2 does its job to deal
with that at the application
layer.
And it's super important.
Another important
thing is that you--
the server, or the
client, whoever
initiates a stream within
the long-lived persistent
connection-- can tell the other
side how important that stream
is in among all the other
streams that are currently
running.
So a server can say,
hey there client,
here's the main webpage.
And now you're going to want to
focus on this JavaScript file.
It's super important.
It's jQuery, and we can't
do anything without that.
And you'll need the CSS next.
And all those avatars for all
users, those are important.
But they're third.
So don't get those before
you get the JavaScript.
Because it's really important
to have the JavaScript.
And then the client
can prioritize
how it handles the
incoming packets.
And you can get a much
lower latency page
load, a much better
user experience.
And either client or server
can initiate a stream.
You can say, hey server, I'm
sending you up some updates.
Say it's a mail application.
It's really important that
you processes these emails
that I'm posting before you
process the whatever, the IMs.
Maybe the emails are more
important, or vice versa,
whatever it might be.
So that's super cool features.
And then as a minor
sort of bonus,
HTTP/2 compresses the headers
of HTTP requests and responses.
In the old days, you
could compress the bodies,
but sometimes the
headers would get big.
If you have like
millions of cookies,
or just huge lists of options,
and you keep repeating them--
sometimes it can be
nice to compress those.
So now we can.
It can be useful.
But all of that goodness
only works on TLS.
There's two reasons for that.
One is we really
want the future web
to be safe so that
it can be appy.
If you think about your
mobile apps, and even
Windows and OS10, but
certainly iOS and Android,
all of those apps pretty much
have to be, these days, signed.
You can't get into
the Android store
without your developer key, you
can't get into the iOS store
without your
developer certificate,
so that people can believe
that they've got the real app.
Well, if we want to have that
same goodness, HTTPS is that.
TLS is that for the web.
But the second reason, that
relates to performance,
is that we need to have
end-to-end reliability
to deliver all that goodness,
all those multiplexed streams
and the header compression.
We need for our communications
between client and server
to be opaque to all these
meddling middle boxes, all
those people who want to insert
their own ads into your stream.
They're also doing
things like, oh, I'm
going to optimize your site
for you by stripping out
some of your headers.
It looks kind of big.
I'm just going to get
rid of those for you.
Well, maybe you needed those.
Maybe your app depended on that.
Or maybe they're
going to say, oh,
I'm just going to
downscale all your images.
It's better, trust us.
And the users are like, why
does everything look so fuzzy,
or whatever.
Or there is passive
eavesdroppers.
Mean time to Snowden
is 11 minutes.
Passive eavesdroppers,
active tampers
who are not messing
with your traffic
for the purpose
of inserting ads,
but may be inserting spamware,
adware, or fraudware,
or spyware.
All those sorts of
things can happen.
Whether they're for
nominally good reasons
or for nominally bad
reasons, we don't even
need to worry about that.
The fact is, HTTP/2 looks
so different on the wire,
that all those middle boxes
that are expecting to see HTTP/1
will do the wrong
thing when they
try to help by
mangling your traffic.
So we know from experience
that it's really, really hard
to get a successful HTTP/2
deployment over not-TLS.
Over plain TCP, all sorts
of breakage happens.
So we need the reliability.
If you think about
it, inside a computer,
you've got your USB
wires and your PCIe.
Well, we're building a
planet-sized computer.
And the message bus is all
the air, all the copper.
And basically, anyone
could be messing with it.
And they are.
So we need the basic
safety that TLS provides.
In fact, this argument has
been going around and around
since the very beginning
of the internet.
If you haven't read it yet, you
should read this great paper
by Jerry Saltzer from 1980.
I think there was
drafts of it in 1979.
And he's trying
to define what he
calls a careful file transfer
application, which is basically
what we're doing here, HTTP.
And he says, so
if you were going
to try to build such a
thing, you'd want the server
to tell the client,
here's your file.
And you want the client
to have some reason
to believe they got the
full file with no damage.
How would you do that?
You could build reliability
stuff at the ends.
Or you could try to
build reliability stuff
in the middle.
You could have the
telephone network
try to make some kind of promise
of reliability or something
like that.
But instead, he
argued that the place
to put the reliability
guarantee is at the endpoints.
And any reliability guarantees
that happen in the middle--
or if you will, at lower
layers in the network
stack-- those are nice
optimizations if they work,
which is not always.
So if you really care,
do it at the endpoints.
And that's, again, what TLS
gives us cryptographically.
It cryptographically gives
us server authentication,
data integrity, and
data confidentiality.
What we mean by that, when I
say "cryptographically," what
I mean is that it would
be computationally
infeasible for one of
those middle layers
to get away with
messing with your stuff.
They could, but it
might take more energy
than there is in the sun,
so we'll call that good,
hopefully-- if the
cryptographers have done
their job right, and
they usually have.
They're much smarter than me.
So really, security
and reliability
are kind of the same thing.
Security is reliability even
when people are purposefully
messing with you.
Reliability is like, oh, there's
noise, and there's bad weather,
and lightning strikes caused
that server to go down, bummer.
Security is when it was
not a lightning strike,
it was a bomb, or some crazy
person inserting their own ads.
And since the message
bus is the planet,
we must, and should, assume
that we're always under attack.
This all sounds good.
I want to have all those
nice benefits of HTTP/2.
I want to provide
safety to my users.
I want my privacy
policy to be true.
I want people to
feel good, and happy,
and safe when
they're using my app.
But I've heard that
TLS is really slow.
Isn't it really slow?
How can we fix that?
Hmm.
So there's several shades
of answer to that question.
If you think of it
not as a Boolean,
but as like an
8-bit wide answer,
the high-order six bits
are all, no, it's not slow.
And the low-order two
bits are, well, we
could probably tune
up a couple things.
So my colleague Ilya
Grigorik has a cool website,
which if you haven't seen
it, you should visit,
that expands on why all those
high-order six bits are zero.
It's called istlsfastyet.com.
And the answer
is, yes, except we
need to get more
people using it.
And he's also got
a really good book
about optimizing
those last two bits.
But let's think
about making sure
that TLS always fits into
our performance budget.
If we want to say we have 1,000
milliseconds before people will
get bored and look
away, we've got
to make sure we
meet that deadline.
So let's do what
we can to make sure
that TLS is not the thing
that breaks it, right?
So the first thing to do is
optimize the higher layers
first-- the content
layer, the HTTP layer.
And HTTP/2 is all about building
in a lot of those HTTP layer
optimizations into the protocol
so that you don't have to.
And it gives you
more knobs to tune,
like prioritizing different
file types and stuff.
But the content
layer is a huge cost.
And a lot of websites--
maybe even most websites--
are paying way too much
there, in my experience.
So here's some-- oh, I've
got my examples coming later.
Yes, they're coming.
So think about--
when you're thinking
about how to optimize,
at the higher levels
or at the lower
levels, you want to go
through a workflow like this.
Start by setting a
quantified target.
If you don't have a quantity--
like 1,000 milliseconds,
or each page load must be
less than 50 kilobytes,
or whatever-- then,
by definition,
you don't have a problem.
And that might seem obvious.
But in my previous
life, I did a lot
of consulting where I would
beg people to turn on HTTPS.
And they would
say, it's so slow.
And I would say, well,
how fast is it now?
And they would
say, I don't know.
But it's got to be
as fast as possible.
And it's like,
well, that's true.
It should be as
fast as possible.
But if you don't know how
fast or slow it is now,
then you don't know
if TLS would hurt.
And they never
liked that answer.
So then I had to draw
pictures for them
and give them examples.
So assuming you've got a
quantified target-- and 1,000
milliseconds is a pretty good
target-- measure the status
quo.
And we'll talk about
measuring in a moment.
Where are you at now?
Are you already,
even without TLS,
not meeting your guarantee?
Well, got work to do.
Or maybe you already
are, and we're good.
Let's stay there.
And assuming you're not, you
can play this circle game
of checking all the red squares.
How many connections
are you making?
How many resources
are you downloading?
How many bytes is each
of those resources?
Reduce all those
things-- how many
TCP handshakes, how
many DNS lookups?
I've seen sites where
just because they wanted
to parallelize all
the 50 resources
they load per page load,
they would parallelize it
over 25 CDNs.
And looking up 25 host
names blew their budget
before making any TCP
or HTTP connections.
So well, maybe too much
parallelism can be a bad thing.
And again, HTTP/2 does a
lot of this stuff for you.
But it still matters
at the content layer.
So do all that.
Measure the status quo again.
How are we doing?
Have we met our
guarantee or not?
Maybe go back.
Maybe you've met
a new guarantee,
and you'd like to tighten
your quantified goal.
So that's great.
Obviously, now you
can do even better,
500 milliseconds
instead of 1,000.
That would be sweet.
When you feel you're happy,
you can go to the green circle
and be done.
And then when you add TLS, you
can do this exercise again,
make sure you're still meeting
your budget, whatever it is.
And if not, fix some stuff.
So to recap, TLS underlies all
those performance guarantees.
So we have to have it.
And I admit, TLS is not free.
I like to do this.
Let's have a poll.
So there's all those
things of TLS-- the server
authentication, the data
integrity, and the data
confidentiality.
There's a lot of
crypto going on.
And there's additional network
traffic to do the handshake.
So who thinks that the symmetric
cryptography, the encryption
of the data, is the
slow thing of TLS?
Anyone think that?
Nobody thinks that?
That's interesting, because
everyone else on the internet
does think that.
They're wrong.
You're all right,
so good on you.
Another thing that
could be slow is
the asymmetry chromatography,
the public/private key pairs
where you say, hi, I'm
really twitter.com,
and no one could, in the
lifetime of the universe,
falsify this guarantee
that I'm about to make you.
And then the clients says, well,
let me just check that math.
Is that slow?
Any hands?
Some hands, not zero.
Those of you who raised
your hands are about right.
That's slower stuff.
It's fixable, but yeah, you're
going to pay some price there.
It's going to be like
in the milliseconds.
You'll notice it.
And that's a bummer.
And then the third thing
that might cost us time
is the network, the additional
part of the handshake.
Who thinks that's expensive?
Many more people-- and
again, you are right.
That's the thing.
So when you're
worrying about TLS,
worry first about
that network overhead.
Worry second about
that asymmetric crypto.
Don't worry about
the symmetric crypto.
Think about it like this.
We can watch DRM video, right?
So it's being
symmetrically decrypted,
and then blasted to your GPU.
And nobody ever even knows
that the video is encrypted,
because it just does not matter.
So don't worry about it.
So worry about
the network stuff.
So we can amortise those
costs-- after, of course,
working on our content layer.
So what you want to
do is, at every stage,
in that playing the red
square game, keep measuring.
And Chrome provides you
some nice measurement tools.
I'm a huge fan of the DevTools.
They're super nice, as
hopefully you already know.
There's this network
tab that tells you
what Chrome is doing on the
network to load your app.
And I'll say "app"
instead of "site."
So here's a page load.
I visit the "New York
Times" every day.
And I'm always interested to see
what is going on content-wise.
It's very heavy weight.
And before you laugh, make sure
that your site isn't like this.
I don't use them
to pick on them.
I use them because it's
just a super common site
that everybody visits.
So we can see a couple
things in this network tab.
It tells us the status
and type of each request,
how many seconds it
takes to load the page,
and where in time
the request happened.
Here we are, 57 requests.
I just visited just
the front page.
We've already transferred
half a megabyte,
and whichever request we're
on here-- maybe it's 15.
We're toward the
bottom, I guess.
We're one, two,
three seconds in.
And we can also see how big each
resource is-- 4 kilobytes, 500,
whatever it might be.
So there's a couple good things
about how the "New York Times"
site loads, some bad stuff.
And make sure that we
want to move things
into the good category.
So first thing, they sprited
their many little icons.
So obviously, if you figure
there's like 50 icons there,
you definitely would not
want to make 50 requests
to get them all.
So you sprite them.
And that helps a lot.
So make sure you're doing
that if you're not already.
Because the overhead of
starting a new network
connection for each of
those would really kill you.
And then TLS would
look really bad,
if you made 50, just to
get little bitty icons.
So there's some bad
stuff about their site
that they could easily fix.
First, we have here
some JavaScript.
It's gzipped, which
is super good.
Always make sure
you're doing that.
But even gzipped, it's
still 62 kilobytes.
So think about
what a browser has
to do to parse and
execute all that code.
62 kilobytes compressed-- so
multiply it by five, or eight.
So pretty soon, you're
talking about a lot of code.
And that's just one of many.
Here is another JavaScript--
not compressed, for some reason.
And it's set to never cache.
It says, specifically,
don't cache this.
Well, it turns out it's
often exactly the same text,
so they could have cached it.
And certainly, they
could have compressed it.
So make sure you're always
caching and compressing
as much as you can.
And here's a trouble spot that
would be the kind of thing that
would make TLS
seem too expensive,
but really the
cost is elsewhere.
So here's a CSS file
that contains within it
a base64 encoded font.
And the base64
encoding multiplies it
by what ratio, anyone?
Four over three-- someone said
four over three, which is true.
So it's bigger
than it needs to be
because of how
they've encoded it.
And then they set it to
cache for only 300 seconds.
And it's half a megabyte.
So every five
minutes, you're going
to get another half megabyte
font file that's probably
the same as it was
five minutes ago.
So don't live in this world.
That would be sad.
That would be slow.
That will blow your budget.
So in addition to
Chrome DevTools,
it's also good to
look a layer below.
Look at the TCP, and
DNS, and IP layers.
So who has used Wireshark?
Hopefully some people--
good, many of you, great.
So you can see
lots of good stuff,
including what's going on at
the TLS layer in Wireshark.
And I find that it's
always an eye opener.
When I was in consulting world
trying to convince people
that they could
indeed afford HTTPS,
I'd bring up a screen like
this, and many eyes would open.
So there's a couple things
going on in this page.
This one, it's a
very small page load.
It only took a quarter of a
second to get all the packets.
There's only about 18 total.
We can see at the bottom,
there's no visible text.
It doesn't look like a web page.
It's all cypher text.
And that's what you want all
those ad inserting people
to see, is nothing.
All those people, all
those passive surveillers,
all those tamperers, you don't
want them to be able to do it.
So that's good.
We can see that that's working.
And then we see that the size
of the packets is mostly small.
There is one thing that
stands out, though.
The Server Hello, which
contains the certificate,
is like 2,700,
2,800 bytes, which
is also about the same
size as the whole web page.
So that's a bummer.
I would really like to amortise
that cost, and reduce it.
So one thing you want
to do is make sure
that your TLS sessions
live as long as possible so
that you don't need
to re-handshake TLS.
I don't know if you knew this.
You can restart an
existing TLS session
that the client and
server have already
negotiated over a totally
different TCP connection five
minutes, or five days,
later, if either side is
keeping a cache that long.
So make sure that your
server is configured
to keep TLS sessions
alive as long as
possible so that you don't
pay that expensive network
thing very often.
And also, things like
HTTP persistence,
and pipelining, or HTTP/2
streams get the most benefit
from the handshake
that you do pay for.
Also, you want to make sure
that that initial stuff, all
the setup, the TCP
setup, and the TLS setup,
falls within the initial
congestion window in TCP.
If they don't, you'll
have to wait just
for the acts for your handshake.
And that will slow
you down badly.
The good news there
is that it's becoming
a standard internet-wide to
make that congestion window much
larger.
In the old bad days,
that 2,700, 2,800 bytes
might have blown the budget.
But these days,
usually, often-- and you
can check with Wireshark
and libpcap, and other tools
that you are in fact not
blowing the initial congestion
window just with your handshake.
Because that can be a bummer.
So these days you have
a lot more head room,
maybe as much as 5,000
bytes, maybe even 8,000.
And that helps a lot.
But if your server
certificate is really big,
or the chain is
unnecessarily long,
or if your CA gave
you a certificate that
includes their logo-- some of
them have JPEGs of the logo.
It's like, well, those
bytes are wasted.
And those are the most important
bytes, those starting bytes,
so don't get caught there.
So just by looking,
almost everybody-- and I'd
be surprised if any of
you are already at a point
where your app was already
maximally optimized
at each of the layers.
So just by looking, you can
discover lots of headroom
where you can introduce safety.
And overall, I should
note that in this move
to SPDY and HTTP/2, in certain
cases, by going to HTTPS,
Google has experienced an
overall latency reduction, not
an increase.
Even an affordable
increase would be cool.
But oftentimes, we're
actually able to do better
by introducing end-to-end
security and reliability.
And it's good for users.
So thanks for hanging out.
And I'll be at the panel,
I think, immediately next.
There's a booth.
So come yell at me if I'm wrong.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]